with this administration it's really
difficult to know if they're telling the
truth because they lie so much and they
also lie about so many different things
they've lied about big policy issues and
they've lied about seemingly unimportant
things like crowd size at Donald Trump's
inauguration and they've also lied about
personal things right whether or not
Trump paid off a porn star after an
affair or whether he knew that she had
been paid off but there is one somewhat
reliable way to get an inkling about
what the truth is and that's the
following
if White House press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders doesn't adamantly
unequivocally deny something you can
start to get the sense that it's
probably true and don't get me wrong
sometimes even when she does adamantly
deny it she still is lying like that's
happened as well but especially when she
works around just denying something that
any reasonable person would say if it
weren't true no that's simply not true
you start to get the sense sense that
there is some likely truth to what a
reporter is asking her about and this is
exactly what happened yesterday when
Sarah Huckabee Sanders was asked about
the existence of these recordings of
Donald Trump throwing the N word around
not quoting a historical figure not
using the n-word rhetorically right but
just referring to black people in this
way and Sarah Huckabee Sanders didn't
deny that there may well be recordings
of Donald Trump saying that so we're
gonna play the clip for you and we're
gonna break it down into multiple pieces
and the reason I'm doing that is that
it's important to parse each answer one
by one because if you step back and you
watch the minute and a half or two
minutes you can get tricked into
thinking well I heard no admissions in
that entire 90 or 120 seconds why are
they badgering her so much but when you
break it down answer by answer as we're
going to do you very quickly realize
that there's no denial in any of the
opportunities to deny it I'll show you
what I mean here's just the first one
okay ten seconds
the president addressed that question
directly via Twitter I'd refer you back
to him I can certainly say I've never
heard him use that term or anything so
first answer right this is the first of
these so-called denials which aren't
denials the first answer is she never
heard him use the n-word now whether
that's true or not is not the question
the question is are you aware of the
president having used the n-word is
there a denial that the president has
ever used the n-word let's continue with
the next piece of this moment president
I didn't have to because he addressed it
to the American people all at one time
again the president answered that
question directly on Twitter earlier
today so the next question is did the
president actually say to you Sarah I've
never used the n-word and she says he
didn't have to this means no the
president hasn't told me that there's no
chance that he's on tape using that
language let's continue and pay
attention no denial at all
any context I can't guarantee anything
but I can tell you that the president
addressed this question directly I can
tell you that I've never heard it I can
also tell you that if myself or the
people that are in this building serving
this country every single day doing our
very best to help people all across this
country and make it better
if at any point we felt that the
president was who some of his critics
claimed him to be we certainly wouldn't
be here this is a president who is
fighting for all Americans who is
putting policies in place that help all
Americans particularly African Americans
so now this is total spin its total
talking point coma she says directly I
can't guarantee that there are no
recordings of the president using the
n-word about black people but then she
does this great thing which is she says
I can assure you if the president was as
bad as his critics claim he is I
wouldn't be working for the president
first of all there is no evidence
whatsoever that that's actually true but
once again that's not the question the
question isn't is Trump as bad as the
worst things ever said about him the
question is simply does he throw the
n-word around and might that word have
been recorded and she then uses that we
wouldn't work for him if he was such a
bad person she uses that to transition
directly into the talking point coma
about helping everyday Americans some of
whom happened to be black this is called
the pivot and it continues for nearly 45
seconds just look at the economy alone
this president since he took office and
the year-and-a-half that he's been here
has created 700,000 new jobs for African
Americans that's 700,000 African
Americans that are working now that
weren't working when this President took
place when President Obama left after
eight years in office eight years in
office he had only created 800 or 190
5,000 jobs for African Americans why
President Trump in his first year and a
half has already tripled what President
Obama did in eight years not only did he
do that for African Americans but for
Hispanics 1.7 million more Hispanics are
working now
this is a president who cares about all
Americans who is committed to helping
them and is putting policies in place
that actually do that those Hispanics
better be damn grateful to this guy so
remember the question was can you
guarantee Trump's not on tape using the
n-word about black people and what she
responds with is as jobs are created
some of them by mere statistical
distribution go to black people that
says nothing about Trump's views about
minorities or whether he's on tape
saying the n-word but it does sound like
she's answering the question and in the
end trumps probably on tape using the
n-word because now we've got yesterday a
recording that leaked were three of
trumps black campaign staffers were
discussing how to spin something
horrible Trump had said every indication
is that it was the use of the n-word
although it hasn't yet been proven and
now you have Sarah Huckabee Sanders who
listen if someone came to you pat and
they said Pat can you guarantee David's
not on tape using the n-word about black
people you'd come to me and ask me and
I'd say oh I don't use that word so
there couldn't possibly be a recording
and then you go back and you say no yeah
I can guarantee you that that doesn't
exist now I do a show where I've
sometimes been quoting something and use
the word so there's sort of specific
circumstances but these are not
difficult questions if the answer's no
no I think that you know there's the the
report that she may be leaving the Trump
administration at the end of the year
that was reported by CBS News so she
could just be trying to salvage whatever
is left for her reputation for her
future job prospects yeah and as she
guarantees that there's no recording of
Trump using the n-word and then a week
later that tape drops that's really
gonna look bad for her and hurt her
future prospects I'm more convinced than
at any previous point that the
recordings exist and the question now is
will the recordings be released and
we'll ultimately see